hey guys it is the 29th of April my name
is Jessa McDonald and you're watching
games but you can armies PT will be gone
from the PlayStation Store later today
but it will be far from forgotten thanks
to a number of PS wars with the game
installed going up on eBay for almost 2
grand
PG 24/7 have reported that multiple eBay
auctions have launched four PS wars with
the soon-to-be unattainable game
installed to such auctioneers from the
UK are asking for the equivalent of
fifteen hundred US dollars while another
from the US is selling his ps4 with PT
and five other games for a current
highest bid of three hundred and
nineteen bucks if it's not going already
it might be worth your while to grab the
playable teaser for the now cancelled
silent hill's before it's pulled down
the director of Final Fantasy 15 has
addressed a bunch of issues that fans
have with the game's demo in fact he's
taken the top 15 complaints and
addressed them one by one
Eurogamer compiled the responses of
director Hajime Tabata and marketing
manager Akio Fujii taken from Square
Enix's monthly video podcast complaints
addressed included one that said the
camera was too close to the character
and rather sluggish to which Tabata said
they'd consider letting the player also
camera distances and if they make the
camera smoother in reference to a
complaint about frame drop issues Tabata
called this a high priority issue and
said that while they are working toward
full HD framerate is more important than
resolution they also responded to
criticisms that Cindy's design was quote
too sexy on this point
Tabata said she wasn't supposed to be in
erotic character simply energetic
cheerful and outgoing no real
clarification on how that accounts for
her unzipped top and barely there shorts
but Tabata says they won't be changing
the current concept finally steam is all
set to get its first adults-only rated
game when hatred arrives this June
if you need a refresher hatred is the
well murder simulator being developed by
destructive creations which has caused
quite a bit of controversy and got taken
down from Steam before people complained
about it and it was reinstated whether
you're on board with the game or not the
origin of the game's release date is
pretty damn entertaining creative
director Yaroslav szalinski told
Eurogamer
initially we were planning to announce
the release date for hatred on May 19th
but well honestly speaking we will be
playing The Witcher 3 then both studios
operate out of Poland it's likely that
hatred won't make it over to consoles
since Nintendo Sony and Microsoft all
have policies forbidding the publishing
of air rated games on their platform let
me know down in the comments if you're
happy to see steam open its doors to
adults only rated games and why or why
not
you can add to GameSpot or we've got
stories on the free PlayStation and Xbox
games you can get in May with their
respective online subscriptions that is
it for me today be sure to let me know
what you cared about and like how - same
time tomorrow
[Music]